>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Sue Vita: Good
evening everyone.
I'm Sue Vita, the chief
of the music division here
at the Library of Congress.
And I am really so
pleased to welcome you all
to the Montpelier Room
for another installment
in the Library of Congress
American Musicological Society
lecture series.
Maybe I need to pull this
down a little further.
This is meant to share
the meaningful scholarship
that members of the
society have conducted
in the music division's
vast collections.
I remember sitting at the
conference in 2007, I think,
and talking about
starting this series.
And wondering whether
it would be something
which could succeed
and could endure.
And so delighted to see
how well we have done.
And what good scholarship
we have been able
to highlight throughout
the series.
We inaugurated the series with
a presentation from Judith Tick
about her research on
Ruth Crawford Seeger.
And since then AMS members
have come to the library
to present research on a
diverse array of topics
from Schoenberg to "Show Boat."
Tonight we will learn more
about uncovering Jewish activism
within our sheet
music collections.
Specifically in the
Irene Heskes collection
of Yiddish American
popular songs.
Tonight's lecture is
being recorded for webcast
and will be made available on
the Library of Congress website
and You Tube channel along
with the nearly 20
lectures presented thus far
in the series.
It is our hope, aside
from celebrating
musicological research
in the music divisions
collection,
that the series inspires other
scholars to take advantage
of the Library of Congress
and our music collections,
both online and in
the reading room.
I am now pleased to introduce
Dr. Ronit Seter, who specializes
in contemporary music
and Israeli music.
And has served on the faculties
of the Peabody Conservatory
at Johns Hopkins.
George Washington University.
Hebrew university of Jerusalem.
And American University
in Washington DC.
She is also affiliated with the
Jewish Music Research Centre,
Hebrew University of Jerusalem.
Let's welcome to the
microphone Dr. Seter,
who will offer greetings
from the American
Musicological Society
and introduce tonight's
guest lecturer, Dr. Seter.
[ Applause ]
>> Ronit Seter: Thank you, Sue.
I would like to welcome you
to our actually celebratory 20th
lecture of the lecture series
of the American Musicological
Society in collaboration
with the music division of
the Library of Congress.
This lecture completes
actually ten years
of these fruitful collaboration
of two distinguished
lecture [inaudible].
All available as webcast if
you just search AMSLC lectures.
As Sue said, we begin
here in 2008.
And it was in the
Coolidge Auditorium
with Sue introducing Judith
Tick and Ruth Crawford.
These lectures are
presented by musicologists
to help conduct research
here or virtually here,
now you can do it all
virtually online, the archives
of the music division
that Sue heads.
These presentations
are obviously
and generally supported
by the help
of the music division's
excellent librarians.
So we are all indebted to you.
Thank you.
I had the honor to give two
presentations actually here
at the Library of Congress.
Not part of this series though.
They were invited by the Hebraic
section and were delivered
in the African and Middle
Eastern Reading Room.
But they were certainly
centered on the field
of Jewish studies in music.
And as a co-founder with Klara
Moricz of the AMS study group
on Jewish studies and music in
2010, I'm especially honored
to be requested on behalf
of the American Musicological
Society to welcome you.
And to introduce
you, to introduce
to you tonight our speaker,
Professor Randall Goldberg.
Goldberg is associate professor
of musicology and director
of the Dana School of Music
at Youngstown State
University in Ohio.
He's a contributor to the
CPE Bach, The Complete Works,
focusing on Carl Philip Emanuel
Bach, Saint Luke passions.
And also to the Oxford
Dictionary of the Middle Ages.
He [inaudible] dissertation
at Indiana University,
looked at the Zarlino-Galileo
dispute.
Beyond early and baroque
music, he just revealed,
just to reveal a bit of
his encyclopedic knowledge,
Professor Goldberg primary
instrument is guitar.
And he directs the early music
ensemble in his institution.
He taught choruses on various
topics like rock and roll.
German opera of the
19th century.
American song.
Gustav Meyer.
And musical borrowings.
However, his current research
in the last few years focuses
on the music of Jewish
immigrants in America.
Goldberg is also doing a lot of
work as a public musicologist.
He was the past president
of the Allegheny Chapter
of the American Musicological
Society.
And currently he's serving as
the executive committee board
of directors of the Youngstown
Jewish Community Center.
Goldberg has presented
on this topic at public
and academic forums,
including the conference
on Jewish music,
Jewish identity.
Which he actually
organized and hosted
in Youngstown University
in 2014.
The conference presented
some of the leading scholars
in the field of Jewish studies
in music whose work Goldberg
edited in a special volume
of the "Journal of Music
Identities" earlier this year.
Just published.
Goldberg also publishes in
"Musica Judaica and Notes."
And he's a very proud father of
two kids that are here today.
His presentation today is
titled "The Kishineff Massacre
and Domestic Musical
Practice in America."
It unfolds the broad context
of Herman Shapiro's
1904 solo piece piano
by the same name,
"Kishineff Massacre."
It is a descriptive
composition written just a year
after the first Kishineff
Pogrom.
And Goldberg chose to invite
to this presentation the
musicologist Jonathan Yaeger,
who is also a pianist organist
and on the music history faculty
at Juilliard, who
focuses on music politics
and the culture of
post-war Germany.
I'm certainly looking
forward to the opportunity
to hear the musical examples
live with pianist Yaeger.
Goldberg presented
earlier version
of these Kishineff Massacre
presentation not only
in his own 2014 Youngstown
Conference
on Jewish Music and
Jewish Identity.
But also at the AMS national
meeting in Louisville, 2015.
And in SUNY Fredonia in 2016.
I'm looking forward very
much to hear this version,
which will be available
for all of us as a webcast
at the AMS Library of
Congress lecture series.
Please join me in welcoming
professor Randall Goldberg.
[ Applause ]
>> Randall Goldberg:
Good evening
and thank you all for coming.
And thank you, Ronit,
for that introduction.
I'm grateful to have
this opportunity
to present my research
in this forum
and share this unique
piece of history.
I especially want to acknowledge
Bob Judd Executive Director
of the AMS.
And Kate Miller and David Plylar
of the Library of Congress
who have been so helpful in
setting up my accommodations.
My logistics.
Spreading word about the event.
So thanks very much.
I also want to thank my
dear friend Jonathan Yaeger
for being here and playing
piano for this presentation.
I'll begin by telling you a
little bit about how I got
into this research project.
About a year after I
completed my Ph.D. dissertation
on Italian Renaissance music
theory, I just happened
to be minding my own business
at the Youngstown
Jewish Community Center.
When the executive director of
the center approached me to see
if I was interested in taking
home the JCC's collection
of dusty 78 RPM records.
He was just looking for a
chump who could help them clean
out some closet space.
But I'm kind of a sucker for
free records and free CDs
and other media like that.
So I took the bait.
The collection contains
many sacred recordings
by star cantors.
Novelty songs.
Comedy skits.
There're even some records
that have Yiddish songs
and Latin dance craze
tunes on the other side.
So what I did was I started
looking at the records and ended
up making a little
database of them.
And I thought this is
interesting, but, you know,
what would happen if I
looked at more records?
And I ended up creating a
database of about 6,000 records,
which I did from
using online catalogs
and printed discographies.
And basically getting
information,
reputable information from
wherever I could find it.
I also spent some
time at the YIVO,
which is the Yiddish
Institute in New York City.
And also at, residency at
the Judaica Sound Archives
in Florida Atlantic University.
In that initial collection
the disc
that interested me
most was a recording
of a descriptive overture
called the "Kishineff Pogrom."
And I had two questions
for this record.
First of all, why would
Jews want to listen to it?
And, you know, why would
anyone want to listen
to a musical depiction
of a recent atrocity?
What's the point?
Wasn't living it enough?
So that was my first question.
And the second question was,
you know, what are the sounds
on these records
supposed to represent?
If this describes a pogrom,
how do I connect the
notes to what a pogrom is?
So investigating these things,
I found that there's actually
a fascinating history here.
And I put it all
together with mostly
by studying sheet music
that's in the Irene Heskes
and other collections in
the Library of Congress.
So another reason
why I'm very glad
to present this research here.
In case you're not familiar with
the Kishineff Pogrom, Kishineff
or Chisinau is the
current capital of Moldova.
And at the time of
the pogrom in 1904,
Jews made up about 30
percent of the population.
In the years leading up to
the pogrom, the "Bessarabetz,"
a local newspaper edited
by the rabid anti-Semite
Pavolaki Krushevan,
printed a number of articles
against the Jewish community.
In 1903 he found
the perfect catalyst
to set off the violence
that was to come.
Two Christian children had
been found dead in the area
around Kishineff and
Krushevan claimed
that Jews had murdered the
children and drained their blood
to make matzo for Passover.
And this is a classic kind
of lie told about Jews
when people need to justify
violence against them.
And in case you're not
familiar with Jewish practice,
Jews have never used
blood to cook.
It's not kosher, so it's just
not something we would do.
Nevertheless, on Easter
Sunday of that year,
mobs headed into the
Jewish areas of the city.
And they murdered many
people, and then they raped
and pillaged for several days.
It was this atrocity
that inspired the music
that I'm now going to discuss.
The Kishineff Pogrom of 1903 is
one of many events memorialized
in Judaism's tragic past.
Although the number of
casualties does not compare
with the Holocaust or
even many other pogroms,
the massacre had a great
influence on Jewish activism,
even for those who will
already immigrated to America.
Indeed, in a 2013
lecture on Kishineff
at the YIVO Institution
for Jewish Research,
historian Steven Zipperstein
claimed that the fallout
of the pogrom inspired
Jewish-American involvement
in not only the creation
of the NAACP and the ACLU,
but also the election of
President Barack Obama.
Furthermore, Zipperstein argues
that the extraordinary response
to Kishineff, which
played heavily in American
and Yiddish-American newspapers,
was fuelled by an
important Zionist leader
who coincidentally
resided in Kishineff.
Indeed, Yakov Bernstein-Kogan
directed a Zionist post office
out of Kishineff, which he used
to communicate activities
throughout Russia and beyond.
In the immediate
aftermath of the pogrom,
he energized his network of
international connections
to disseminate information
about the violence.
Descriptions and
eyewitness accounts
in the press were accompanied
by benefit concerts.
Poetry. Books.
And new music.
The speed at which new artifacts
about the pogrom
appeared is remarkable.
In fact, the "New York Times
Tribune" reported in 1903
that one Yiddish theater
staged a dramatic reenactment
of the massacre within 48
hours after it occurred.
Producers of the
reenactment did not strive
for a literal presentation
of the events.
Instead, basing the action
on previous atrocities.
Their underlying messages
about the need for Jews
to find a homeland, however,
were already familiar
and superceded specific details.
I want to briefly show some of
the newspapers from which I've,
getting all this information
about all the press releases.
And these are documents
that you can, anyone can go
to the Library of
Congress website.
And you can actually search
for individual words like
"Kishineff," and it will bring
up where Kishineff
occurs in any paper.
So it's just an amazing tool,
and you can learn
so much from this.
Here's a page from the "New
York Daily Tribune," 1903.
And we can see the
top of this column,
a letter from Kishineff
about the events.
Later down here is an article
about the Russian ambassador
to America who's complaining
that the news is all exaggerated
and it didn't really happen.
Here's another page from
the "St. Louis Republic."
And we see there's an
article about a father,
a family in St. Louis
whose father escaped
and how they're trying
to bring the family
to America from Kishineff.
There's an article about
Israel Zangwill's statements
about the pogrom.
Zangwill was a very
famous playwright
who coined the term
"melting pot."
So he's an important
figure in American letters.
There's just, there's no
end to what you can get
from just doing, you know,
basic archival work
in these newspapers.
Much of the media
coverage strove
to promote a Zionist
agenda as well
as raise funds for the victims.
For example, an article in
the "Brooklyn Daily Eagle,"
seen here, begins
with the question,
What is the lesson of Kishineff?
And responds, Ringing around
the world, loud and clear,
voiced by the great leaders
of Zion comes the answer.
Return to Palestine.
Rebuild the temple.
Resurrect the nation.
Furthermore, new
books on anti-Semitism
in Russia also urged a
solution to the Jewish problem.
The Irish activist and statesman
Michael Davitt visited Russia
immediately after the pogrom.
And wrote articles about it
for William Randolph
Hearst's newspapers.
His reporting served
as the basis
for the book "Within the Pale."
The true story of anti-Semitic
persecution in Russia,
which he published
later in 1903.
Although Davitt claimed to be in
line with the spirit and program
of anti-Semitism, in some cases
he argues that he wrote the book
to put forward a plea for the
objects of the Zionist movement.
In addition to book-length
discussions and reactions
in the newspapers, gruesome
poems like Shimen Frug's
"Hot Rachmunes" or "Have
Mercy" were disseminated widely
to inspire sympathy
in fellow Jews
and raise funds for survivors.
There were also musical works
published in the aftermath.
And the Library of
Congress' collection includes
many examples.
I have just a couple here of
many that you can look at online
or I guess see in the library.
The first, "Hot Rachmunes,"
is a setting of the poem.
Someone took Shimen Frug's
poem and set it as a song.
The second, "The farewell
of the Jews to Kishineff,"
is a descriptive piece
like the work I'm going
to speak in detail about.
And also written as a response
to the pogrom and ways of,
get people involved with the
issues of Jews in Europe.
So there are many
other examples.
I just chose a couple.
Shimen Frug's poem also
inspired Herman Shapiro's 1904
"Kishineff Massacre," a
descriptive work for solo piano.
Featuring a series of
short musical tableau,
Shapiro designed his composition
to bring the severity
of the pogrom into the living
rooms of American Jews.
And we can assume
to move their hearts
to joining the Zionist cause.
Shapiro's affective
score, with its ties
to Western European musical
traditions and foregrounding
of what we might call
stereotypically Jewish elements,
stands out as a useful
point of departure
to discuss how composers
marketed Jewish catastrophe.
Educated listeners and
performers on the plight
of their brethren in Europe.
And pressed for Zionist action.
Shapiro's massacre can also help
us decode other musical media
about Kishineff whose
aesthetic logic is not as clear.
Such as the record which
I will discuss later.
Herman Shapiro appears to
have been quite successful
in marketing tragedy
to Jewish audiences.
The printed preface
to the score of his
"Dr. Herzl Elegy"
includes a testimonial
from a concert he gave in 1899.
And it reads, "There
was given recently
in Louisville a genuine
Hebrew concert.
The program was distinctly
Jewish in character.
The whole tragedy of
Israel found utterance
in the eloquence of the music.
Every feast of gladness
and every day of sorrow
and oppression had
its record in melody."
The same review claims that
everybody present who heard the
"plaintive cry of his
own people" responded
sympathetically to the music.
It seems that Shapiro and his
live performances received the
same reaction from audiences
that he hoped would occur
in the living rooms
and salons of the Jews
who would purchase his
"Kishineff Massacre."
The printed score, published
by Asna Goldberg in 1904,
is a striking as the
music it contains.
The bright red cover, attention
grabbing in its own right,
frames a ghastly
illustration of the pogrom.
In the foreground angry
Russians whip an elderly man
and strangle a young woman while
a naked toddler inexplicably
flies through the air.
A silhouetted mob in
smoke fill the background,
which is outlined by a
whip and a bloody sword.
The macabre image is more than
suitable to attract Jews looking
to contemplate or
memorialize suffering.
And the Yiddish titles betray
the marketing intentions
of the publisher.
Inside the cover we
find a Yiddish text
in the English translation
of Shimen Frug's
poem "Hot Rachmunes."
It's inclusion in the score
and connections to the music,
which I will discuss below,
help us understand the function
of Shapiro's piece as a tool
for domestic entertainment
and edification.
The Kishineff pogrom
may be a novel subject
for a solo piano work,
but the structure
of Shapiro's composition
follows the formula common
to instrumental battle pieces.
Which were popular
in America during
and just after the Civil War.
A full history of
musical depictions
of battles would take
us back centuries
in the Western European
canon and include clever
and entertaining works
by Clement Janequin.
William Byrd.
Heinrich Biber.
And even Beethoven's much
criticized battle symphony
titled "Wellington's Victory."
According to Richard Crawford
in "America's Musical Life,"
however, most American composers
modeled their battle pieces
on the Bohemian Frantisek
Kocvara's "Battle of Prague,"
which was first published
in the 1780s.
Kocvara's setting depicts
Frederick the Great's victory
over the Austrians during
the Seven Years' War
through a series of
short musical episodes.
He writes in common
western musical topics
such as march rhythms,
horn calls and Sturm
and Drang passages to
represent the preparations for
and execution of warfare.
The music was first
published in the U.S. in 1793.
And inspired many new solo piano
works based on American battles
from the Revolutionary
and Civil wars as well
as the Spanish-American
War a century later.
Musicologist Elizabeth Morgan
has recently published research
on Civil War battle pieces.
And her conclusions about
these works are helpful
in understanding Shapiro's
music for Kishineff.
First of all, Civil War
battle pieces were composed
for domestic performances.
Especially by amateur
female pianists.
The importance of acquiring
piano skills for young women
at the turn of the 20th
century is well-documented
in home journals,
music periodicals
and other literature
of the time.
In one 1892 book-length guide
for housewives titled "Queen
of the Home," Emma Churchman
Hewitt considers piano playing
as a key component
of home making.
But lamented conditions in
which "Daughters were expected
to make night hideous
and their lives a burden
by their weary hours
of practice."
Even Jewish women, many of
them being first generation
immigrants, sought to prove
their talents on the piano.
Joseph Rumshinsky, one of the
most prolific Jewish composers
and arrangers of
the Yiddish theater,
published many didactic
musical works.
And describes his
clientele in his memoir
"Klangen fun mayn lebn."
He writes, "From 10:00
in the morning until 3:00
in the afternoon, I taught
young women recently married
who wanted to show their
husbands they could play piano.
From 3:00 until 7:00 I
taught schoolchildren.
And then from until 10:00
or 11:00 in the evening,
I taught shop girls and office
girls who wanted to get married.
Rumshinsky's students may have
been looking for a husband,
but their skills would have
also served as a conduit
for the edifying messages
contained in works
like Shapiro's "Kishineff
Massacre."
The battle pieces served
as an entertaining vehicle
for families to celebrate their
side's military achievements.
Long before Facebook
news feeds and Twitter,
battle pieces also supplemented
journalistic reports.
Providing intricate details of
the fighting with a descriptive
and stirring musical
accompaniment.
Not surprisingly, Northern
publishes printed works based
on Union victories.
And the triumphs
of the Confederacy were
covered by Southern presses.
Shapiro's massacre seems
counterintuitive in this regard
as the pogrom was certainly not
a victory for Jews to celebrate.
On the other hand, the battle
genre offered appropriate means
for transplanted families
to relate to the instability
of Jewish life in Europe
while strengthening the piano
technique of young women eager
to enter respectable society.
Shapiro could have modeled
the composition on reports
of the pogrom posted
in U.S. papers.
As early as May 1903,
the "New York Times"
and "The Sun" published
unsettling eyewitness accounts
of the violence.
But Shapiro's descriptive music
mostly ignores specific details
in favor of stock musical topics
commonly found in battle pieces.
For example, many battle pieces
include a morning bugle call
or reveille.
And this is the one from
Kocvara's "Battle of Prague."
And it's, you know,
it's trumpet music.
This one goes.
[ Music Sounds ]
And so forth.
This is one from the
Battle of Gettysburg.
And, again, very much what
we think of as trumpet music.
[ Music Sounds ]
And so forth.
Although the published accounts
of the pogrom do not
feature a bugle call,
Shapiro includes the
bugle call of the rioters.
[ Piano Music ]
Another obligatory section
of battle pieces is
a musical depiction
of the violent acts
of war itself.
Attack music has a long history
in western classical music.
For one prominent example,
the Italian composer
Claudio Monteverdi suggested
in the 1638 preface of his
eighth book of madrigals
that an agitated or violent
affect could be rendered
in music through a succession
of quick repeated notes.
He put his theory into
use in the dramatic
"Combattimento di Tancredi
e Clorinda" or "Combat
between Tancredi and Clorinda."
In this short excerpt the
narrator describes a deadly duel
between the title characters.
[ Music ]
Monteverdi's so-called
agitated style caught
on throughout Europe.
And could be heard in countless
pieces that describe battles,
storms and violent behavior.
In the late 18th century,
composers for the piano often
used dexterous passage work
at a quick tempo to
represent military action.
And here's the attack music from
Kocvara's "Battle of Prague."
And you can see the
quick Alberti Bass figure
in the piano.
And then these melodic figures,
two of them that I have circled,
I'll come back to in a second.
Shapiro's attack music, what
he labels as the hellish work
in full force, fits
this paradigm.
And the principal motive
is clearly borrowed
from the "Battle of Prague."
So you see the same figure.
It goes kind of like
[music sounds].
And it's the same as the figure
in Kocvara's attack music.
Elizabeth Morgan notes that
in Civil War battle pieces the
attack music always
stays in a major key.
Shapiro, in contrast
to this tradition,
tried to represent an
attack on Jews in his music
and adds chromatic tones
to create Jewish
sounding harmonies.
At first the mode
merely shifts to G minor.
But later on scaler
runs in arpeggios
with augmented seconds
bring the ethnic nature
of the conflict into focus.
So now let's hear both examples.
[ Piano Music ]
Shapiro.
Although the "Kishineff
Massacre" certainly borrows
from the battle music tradition,
it notably does not
contain actual battle music.
Instead Shapiro focuses
on the victims,
directing the listener towards
the work's didactic function.
Many battle pieces include
a brief lamentation section
to represent fallen troops
on either side of the fight.
So here's one from the
"Battle of Waterloo" from 1910.
And you can see it's, the
title "Lamentation," adagio.
So it's slow.
Con expressione or
with expression.
It's a very lyrical and
subdued piece of music.
This is a very interesting
one from Charles Grobe's
"The Battle of Fort Donelson."
And in this case the
music is very choral-like.
Like something a four-part
choir might sing in church.
The music is actually
"My Country Tis of Thee."
And the text is the names
of the Northern soldiers
who had died in the battle.
And you can see them
all listed there.
So if you were performing
this piece at home
and someone was narrating the
work, they would actually read
through all the names, you
know, possibly people you know
who died in the battle.
So it's a very affective
way of lamenting the fallen.
In the "Kishineff
Massacre," however,
Shapiro composes more
lamentation than action,
reserving three of the work's
seven sections for this purpose.
Unlike the other parts
of the composition,
these excerpts predominantly
feature stereotypically
Jewish music.
Slow tempi.
Inflections of the
so-called Ahava Rabbah scale
and cantorial gestures
and ornaments.
The first example, labeled
"The victims in their Agony,"
is a brief depiction of anguish.
Three chords played in tremolo
followed by a plaintive cadenza.
[ Piano Music ]
For the descriptive labels
of the two other examples,
Shapiro draws directly from
the text of Frug's poem.
Emphasizing the connection
between this piece
of musical entertainment
and the campaign
that inspired the poetry.
Of special note is
the third lamentation
"The Living Cry for Bread."
Which eludes to the refrain that
ends each stanza of the poem.
And serves as the finale
of the entire composition.
The refrain reads, "Brethren
sisters, mercy, mercy,
grave and awful is the woe.
Hasten shrouds to wrap the dead,
hasten give the living bread."
"The Living Cry For Bread"
is easily the longest section
in Shapiro's massacre.
Its stately tempo, mournful
character and repetition
of motives heard in the first
two lamentation sections help
create a suitable
anti-finale for the work.
In a recent article on
descriptive piano works,
Jonathan Bellman notes how
Kocvara's "Battle of Prague"
and many other descriptive
works end with a familiar song.
"The Living Cry For Bread"
is certainly the most
song-like section.
And even if it is
original music,
its characteristic
melodic motives are similar
to other plaintive Jewish tunes.
Here is the opening.
[ Piano Music ]
Shapiro's publisher must
have noted the potential for
"The Living Cry For Bread"
to be heard as a paradigm
of tragic Jewish music.
For they included an excerpt of
this section as an advertisement
for Shapiro's work
in the sheet music
for Joseph Rumshinsky's 1906
arrangement of the Yiddish song
"Eli, Eli," a classic of
Jewish pathos throughout the
20th century.
And here's the edition
also from the Library
of Congress collection.
And you can see the cover.
And then when you'd
open the cover,
the first thing you would see
would be this page of music
from Shapiro's work as a
kind of advertisement for it.
Here's what that
tune sounds like.
[ Music ]
You can hear, very
similar in character.
In short, Shapiro's
"Kishineff Massacre" follows
in the tradition of battle
music for solo piano.
But alters it significantly
by directing its performers'
and listeners' attention
towards the tragic losers
of the battle using stock,
stereotypical gestures
to generate sympathy
for the Jewish cause.
It is likely that well-to-do
Jewish families in America
who would have already
been familiar
with the battle genre could
easily understand its new
context and be moved to act on
its charitable exhortations.
While Shapiro's musical
depiction
of the Kishineff pogrom does not
convey the Zionist sentiments
common to the American
press reports, another work
by the composer reveals how his
tragic Jewish battle piece might
be aligned with the
Zionist cause.
Shapiro would draw his audiences
further towards the Jewish
poetics of domestic
music making with his
"Dr. Herzl Elegy"
for solo piano.
Which he published in July
1904, five months after his
"Kishineff Massacre"
and just one month
after the death of
Theodore Herzl.
That Shapiro would
musically honor the life
of the Zionist leader
on the heels
of his Kishineff piece suggests
that his earlier composition
should not stand apart
from the Zionist enthusiasm
that followed the tragedy.
The opening in Dante in G Ahava
Rabbah shares the same tonal
center, G, tempo and character
of "The Living Cry For Bread"
from the "Kishineff Massacre."
Hinting that the
newer work begins
with a previous piece left off.
[ Piano Music ]
All of the remaining sections,
which Shapiro introduces
with either Yiddish odes to
Herzl by George Selikowitz
or descriptive titles, feature
the same musical elements used
to signify Jewishness in
the "Kishineff Massacre."
Furthermore, connections
to European musical topics
are far less apparent
than in the previous work.
In the elegy, the listener is
not invited to hear Jewish music
in opposition to western idioms.
To the contrary, as German
musicologist Jascha Nemtosov
notes in his book "Zionism
in Music," Shapiro turns
to Klezmer, incorporating
authentic sounding tunes
in accompaniment patterns that
mimic the hammered dulcimer.
For example, let's hear
the opening of the section
"Hofnung's Tenor
von Zion's Harf"
or "Hope's Hand on Zion's Harp."
[ Piano Music ]
Shapiro subtitled the
elegy "Funeral meditations
on the death of the Jewish
Siegfried, Zion's architect."
A reference to the mythic
German hero and subject
of Richard Wagner's
"Ring Cycle."
It may be surprising that
Theodor Herzl was a huge fan
of the anti-Semitic
composer Richard Wagner,
but it is quite true.
And Shapiro may have
shared his enthusiasm.
The three flat key signatures
seen throughout the elegy might
be a reference to
Siegfried's funeral music
in Act 3 of Gotterdammerung.
And the musical material
in one section
of the elegy is reminiscent
of a Wagnerian leitmotif.
Other parts of the
elegy, however,
show little Wagnerian influence.
In this composition, Jewish
folk styles account for much
of the musical material.
Even in the final movement
labeled "In the Future,"
which is marked allegramente
or cheerfully,
one can imagine a Klezmer
tooting joyfully on a clarinet.
[ Piano Music ]
A comparison with
the sonic world
of "the Kishineff Massacre,"
we might hear the elegy
as a musical realization
of the Zionist dream.
A space in which Jewish
culture dominates throughout.
On the other hand,
Herman Shapiro's most popular
printed work was a collection
of Jewish wedding dances.
And it is just as possible
that to compose the Herzl elegy
quickly he chose Klezmer idioms
because he was already
adept at it
and could complete the elegy
ahead of his competition.
So now let's turn to
the record I found
in the Youngstown
JCC's collection.
It is difficult to
assess the impact
of Shapiro's work
for solo piano.
And because they were
likely played in private,
domestic settings,
it is also unlikely
that we will find concert
programs or reviews
that document performances.
There is evidence, however,
that Shapiro's "Kishineff
massacre" influenced later
musical representations
of the pogrom.
In 1924, the Victor Talking
Machine Company released a
recording by conductor
Nathaniel Shilkret
and the international
Concert Orchestra
of another descriptive
Kishineff massacre.
The marketing classification,
Yiddish descriptive overture
and Yiddish writing
on the disc certified
that this recording was
marketed to Jewish audiences.
Victor discographies
provides some basic details
about the production.
But no information
exists that might tell us
for certain what this
descriptive overture is meant
to describe.
The 1924 recording of
"Kishineff Massacre" follows the
conventions of the
earlier work for piano.
For example, Shapiro's work
begins with a short intro,
"The First Signal of the Storm,"
which features foreboding,
repeated octaves
punctuated with thick chords.
[ Piano Music ]
The opening on the record
includes a similar gesture.
But this time the ominous pedal
point is played by trombones,
the usual harbingers of death
in Western European
classical music.
[ Music ]
The Jews are to be
represented by slow music,
containing orientalist, excuse
me, orientalist inflections
and rhapsodic cadenzas
played on violin or clarinet.
[ Music ]
The violence of the
event is represented
by up tempo attack sections.
The first of which does not
show any stereotypical markers
of Jewishness and
sounds like finale music
for an operatic overture.
[ Music ]
The second up tempo
section, the works finale,
sounds like an Eastern
European dance introduced
by trumpet calls.
Although the ethnic character
of the music is not distinct,
it may reflect the reports
of a journalist who noted
that in the immediate aftermath
of the pogrom indifferent
citizens gathered each evening
in the royal garden in
Kishineff to, quote,
and this is Monte Pancower's
[assumed spelling] translation,
"To enjoy the music
of the dragoon band,
which performed Polish polkas
as well as Hungarian csardas
and Russian marches
in faultless fashion."
[ Music ]
Without further documentation,
we have to use our imagination
to determine the
intended image evoked
by each section of the overture.
The timing of the
recording is peculiar
as it appears during
an era of uncertainty
for Jews in the United States.
According to Eric Goldstein
in "the price of whiteness,"
white America had become
increasingly anxious
in the 1920s about the
so-called Jewish problem.
And debates over
the place of Jews
in American society
carried forth
in published articles,
symposia and exposes.
Furthermore, although America
had been the number one
destination for Jewish
immigrants leaving Europe,
the Johnson-Reed Act of
1924 restricted their entry,
forcing many immigrants
to settle in Palestine.
Given the unstable nature
of Jewish life in America
at that time, it seems odd that
Victor would release a recording
that would remind Jews of
recent atrocities committed
by a host nation.
On the other hand,
record company executives
were not too concerned
about the content of the
ethnic records they produced.
From one example, L.L.C.
Book [assumed spelling],
who was Columbia's
head of ethnic records,
wrote in a 1920 issue of
"Talking Machine World" that
"The foreigner is not particular
in his selection
of foreign music.
Simply he desires
music which reminds him
of his old folks
and his old home.
There's hardly any of
the foreign records
which will not do this."
The recording of the "Kishineff
Massacre" could certainly evoke
memories of Russia, although
not necessarily pleasant ones.
The Victor recording also
suggests how Jewish American
engagement with the plight
of European Jews may have
changed by the 1920s.
In a 1906 essay, "The
Menace of Mechanical Music,"
America's most famous band
leader and composer of the era,
John Philip Sousa raged
against the fledging
phonograph industry.
Above all other complaints,
Sousa argued
that the proliferation
of talking machines would
produce a terrible change
in America's musical culture.
Noting "For when music
can be heard in the homes
without the labor of study
and close application
and without the slow process
of acquiring a technique,
it will be simply
a question of time
when the amateur
disappears entirely."
Although Sousa scholar Pat
Warfield has demonstrated
that Sousa was more interested
in revising copyright laws
than protecting America's
musical heritage,
Sousa's prophecy may be telling.
In 1904, young Jewish women or
men may have practiced Shapiro's
"Kishineff Massacre" for
hours, perfecting their skills
of execution and interpretation.
They would have performed the
piece at family gatherings,
showing off their talents
while sharing the work's
urgent message.
Any one in the house
or apartment during
practice sessions
or performances may have seen
the sheet music, asked questions
and learned about the situation.
The 1924 recording,
on the other hand,
would require much less
engagement from its audience.
And serve more as a
memorial of the pogrom
than a call to action.
Now, I'd like to conclude
by discussing the placement
of this recording in Victor's
catalog of ethnic records.
The international concert
orchestra's discography covers a
variety of ethnic styles.
Which the label could
have easily marketed
to various immigrant groups.
Most of the choices
are nostalgic.
There are waltzes
for the Viennese.
Music by Edvard Grieg
for the Norwegians.
And folk songs for the Russians.
The only international concert
orchestra disc that was marketed
to Jews and features what one
might call Jewish music is this
"Kishineff Massacre."
The listing suggests that,
whereas some immigrant groups
wanted to dance the night away
or sing folk songs,
the Jewish community,
20 years after Kishineff,
preferred to contemplate
their suffering
and fragile safety
among gentile nations.
Perhaps Shapiro's "Kishineff
Massacre" helped establish a
soundtrack for such a practice.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> The battery must be dead.
>> I can talk loud too.
I can talk very loud, okay.
So you talked there at
the end about the printer
or the publisher, Victor and
their context of this record.
I was wondering about
the publisher
of the sheet music itself.
So was that a Jewish publisher
marketing for Jewish audiences?
Or were, did they also
have other, I don't know?
[ Multiple Speakers ]
>> Randall Goldberg:
As far as I can tell,
[inaudible] Jewish publisher.
Asna Goldberg, yeah.
>> Say that again,
Ray, I'm sorry.
>> Randall Goldberg: Yeah,
that was a Jewish publisher.
I don't know if he published
Jewish music exclusively,
but he published a lot of it.
Obviously the ties between
the "Kishineff Massacre"
and the score for a
"Eli, Eli," I mean,
it shows he has a
distinct marketing niche.
And the Hebrew titles on
the, it's Yiddish language
but Hebrew letters
on there, you know,
show who's supposed
to buy that stuff.
Yes.
>> Is Goldberg the first,
Gershwin's first
biographer, I think?
Does anyone know that?
>> Randall Goldberg:
Asna Goldberg?
>> Excuse me, I have
the name wrong.
I'm sorry.
>> Randall Goldberg: Oh, sorry.
>> Never mind.
>> Thank you for an
excellent lecture.
Really well-structured
and very informative.
So in the introduction you,
your dissertation was referred
to as an Italian
Renaissance whatever.
And I'm curious, this is
kind of a far cry from that.
So was there any relationship
in doing this kind of research
to what you originally did
your dissertation work?
What did you bring to
this from that experience?
>> Randall Goldberg: I guess
I can answer that question
by talking about how I got
into Jewish music studies.
Which I did at the
same time I was working
on my dissertation work.
You know, I went to
Indiana University,
and we have a great diverse
musicology faculty there.
And I can also use this time to
thank some of my friends from IU
who are in the audience tonight.
There was a seminar at the time.
I came studying musicology
thinking I would study
early music.
But we also, there's a
terrific scholar at IU,
he's at University of
Illinois now, named Jeff Magee.
And he had a seminar on
Jewish identity in music.
And that's where i
was first introduced
to a lost these ideas.
I had performed Klezmer
music and studied
that just as a performer.
But in that seminar, for which
I was actually the only Jewish
person in it, I really
enjoyed it very much.
And it opened me up to
a lot ways of thinking
about myself and
about this music.
And I did my final project on a
living musician, David Krakauer,
a clarinetist and his music.
And it was from that that I
got interested in this topic.
And then, you know, I decided
to write my dissertation
on Italian music theory
because I really wanted
to learn the language.
And studying, learning
about Galileo's father.
All that stuff was
very fascinating.
But, you know, it's
easy to draw back,
to get into Jewish music for me.
And so this was my
childhood and everything
and growing up in the synagogue.
And then all of a sudden
you're uncovering this history
that you didn't know existed.
You know, so it was very, thing,
and the research was wonderful.
Because every morning I would
get up, I would actually get
to my office at the
university early just
so I would have an
extra 30 or 45 minutes
to build this database.
And through these online
archives, I was, you know,
finding information
of all these records.
And listening to just
hundreds and hundreds
and hundreds of records.
And just realizing how
much stuff was out there.
So I don't know, I think
there's probably some connection
between the early music.
But I think mostly they're just,
I just like a lot of music.
I like everything.
And so any time I
can work on something
that interests me is great.
Thanks for the question.
>> I hope I'm doing this right.
I'm not sure.
But maybe you can
hear my voice anyway.
>> Sure.
>> The "Kishineff Massacre" was
also the impetus for the region
of the American Jewish
Committee in 1906.
And that was a formation
of a group
of wealthy German-Jewish
Wall Street bankers who felt
that the Kishineff
massacre simply could not be
tolerated anymore.
And they had to take
some action.
You mentioned also that
it was the impetus for,
was it Jewish participation
in the formation of the NAACP?
And another group?
>> Randall Goldberg: The ACLU.
>> The ACLU.
Could you expand a little bit.
>> Randall Goldberg:
Mostly what I know is
from Eric Goldstein's book.
But, I mean, or, no, that was
from Steven Zipperstein's
lecture.
But Eric Goldstein talks a
lot about this in the book
"The Price of Whiteness."
And things I know about
Jewish-black relations
from scholars such
as Cheryl Greenberg
who wrote a great
book about that.
You know, I think these
were social issues.
I'm not an expert in this area.
But they were social issues that
Jews, and especially the Jews
in New York, it sort of
established themselves
in America, they wanted
to get involved in.
They were just very active.
And you're right, this pogrom
is seen as a turning point.
I think there's a famous article
about the Kishineff Pogrom
called "The Turning Point,
the Kishineff Pogrom."
I think the ADL was also formed
shortly after this pogrom.
Because it was, the idea
was that Jews need a,
we need somebody
to protect them.
Because living in these towns,
and they have no protection
when these things happen.
As far as their involvement
in the NAACP,
I believe the organization
was started mostly by Jews
as I guess, in a kind of
social activism, saying we need
to protect, you know,
this minority in America.
Because they don't have
people protecting them.
The same with ACLU.
This is an organization that
protects people's rights.
So how, it was the Kishineff
massacre that caused all this
to happen, Zipperstein
at least claims it's
because there was this
person Jacob Bernstein-Kogan
in Kishineff who was very much
involved in political Zionism.
And he knew this was the
kind of political event,
not that he's exaggerating
the event.
But it's, you know,
that's in politics,
right, you use an event.
If I have an agenda,
say it's gun control.
When there's a shooting
somewhere, I'm going to say,
let's talk about gun control.
Here's why.
The Kishineff Pogrom is a great
time for [inaudible] to say,
look, we need a homeland.
Heres why.
And so that just, you know,
spurned all these
other activities.
I don't know much
about the formation
of these organizations though.
>> I believe that
Zipperstein has a book coming
out early next year on
the Kishineff Massacre.
And I believe it's something
like "The Kishineff Massacre
and the Tilt of History."
So that should be
well worth reading.
I was going to ask you,
could you tell us a little
bit more about Shapiro.
Was he born in the U.S.?
How did he come to be so,
have such a career in music?
Obviously, not easy teaching
with a teaching schedule
like that.
But what were some of
his other achievements,
et cetera, et cetera?
>> Randall Goldberg: I
haven't found much about him.
I haven't really dug
into the archives.
When I did some archival
work on this project,
I was studying other musicians.
I came to Shapiro later.
So all I know, you know,
the Irene Heskes catalog here
lists all of his publications.
Obviously, that review
of a concert is conveniently
inside one of his pieces
of sheet music so
anyone can see it.
I really don't know
much about him.
I, you know, I've looked.
I've looked in YIVO.
I couldn't find anything on
YIVO's website or anything
in their library catalog.
So I really don't know.
You know, he's not a musician
who's really been picked
up by other, you know,
performing ensembles.
You don't hear about this
music being performed much.
Because the music is kind of,
it's not really concert
music like Liszt or Chopin.
It's really, you know, was
designed for these, you know,
domestic performances.
So, sorry, I don't know,
I really don't know
much about him.
I'm, it's somewhat, this
paper is very speculative.
Although I think most of it
works together pretty well,
pieces together pretty well.
>> Just curiosity.
Since you started with
the Italian Renaissance
and since there is
one major figure
in the Italian Renaissance,
Jewish background,
Salamone Rossi.
I'm wondering if you have, in
the wanderings across the span
of music, whether you see this
kind of musical expression
as something of an assertion
of a separate Jewish identity.
Whereas most of the
musicians, composers, at least,
in many cases the performers
of Jewish background
in the classical music
tradition going all the way back
to the Renaissance, were kind of
trying to say more like, me too.
I can be a part of a
more mainstream thing.
Whether that is something
of a contrast that you see.
And whether, in fact, something
like a massacre of this,
even though it's not
that large a massacre.
But the effect it has on
the world's imagination,
not just Jewish imagination is
a pivot point in that regard?
>> Randall Goldberg: Thanks.
That's an interesting question.
Yeah, Salamone Rossi is a
perfect example of a composer.
Writes in Hebrew, but it
sounds like Palestrina.
It's just gorgeous polyphony.
When I look at this stuff,
I look through it more,
not so much, I talked about
a lot of the background
of this music and kind
of Western European
classical traditions.
This is more of like
mass-marketed popular music.
And in America around the
turn of the 20th century,
there's so much of this
going on in Tin Pan Alley
and all the publishing houses.
And they're working
very hard to appeal
to distinct marketing niches.
So using these, you know,
almost kind of stereotypes
of what might sound Jewish
works really well to show
that that is supposed
to be Jewish music.
It's a little bit like how in
silent films or in cartoons
or something, if in a cartoon
of a Jewish person comes
on the screen, you have
to hear "Hava Nagila."
It's like, you know, it's a
little bit cartoonish like that.
And it's, yeah, there is
a lot of cantorial music
that sounds like this.
And, you know, certain types
of Jewish worship music
that sound like this.
But it's so much more I think
the composer as marketing
to their audience
to me in a sense.
There are all kinds of
debates at this time.
One is by the writer,
Lazare Saminsky was a
Russian-Jewish composer.
And he writes in his book
on "Music in the Ghetto
and the Bible," saying
that all this kind of,
I hate to use the term
"exotic inflection."
But what musicians would
call augmented seconds.
All these things are
actually corruptions
of real Jewish music.
That the real music of the Bible
wouldn't have had these things.
It was just picked up by Jews
wandering through Central Asia.
So there's always
kind of disputes.
But in America I
think still, you know,
if people want something to
sound Jewish, they play a tune
and they have, you know, they
those intervals in there.
And people say, oh, that's
supposed to represent Jews.
That's the way I'm kind of
looking at it in this paper.
You know, if you look at later
in the 20th century into someone
like Leonard Bernstein.
Some, the things he
puts in his symphonies.
When he's quoting the blessing
before reading a Haftarah
in one of his symphonies.
I mean, clearly he's trying to
create, you know, a Jewish sound
that the Jews will
recognize as being Jewish.
And it's similar to that.
But it's hard for me to think
of Herman Shapiro the same
way I might think of someone
like Felix Mendelssohn.
Because you know he's
someone who is really trying
to show he's part of the
western classical tradition.
Or Meyerbeer or some of
those other composers.
He's writing music
to a mass market.
He's not so much writing
music to please, you know,
the "Neue Zeitschrift
fur Musik" in Germany.
He's writing for his, you know,
for people to buy sheet music.
I don't know if that
answers everything.
>> You mentioned the of
speed of the communication
and the publications in the
U.S. about the massacre.
And I'm curious about the
back influence or knowledge
or awareness of the music, this
composition or the reaction
in America back in,
where it happened.
And the surrounding communities.
>> Randall Goldberg: It's hard.
I haven't found, as
I wrote in the paper,
I really haven't found
documented performances.
Si it's hard, you know, it's
hard to find information
about something people
would have done
at home without doing that.
And it's interesting
because I've had,
with other obscure Yiddish songs
that I've studied as relative
to this research, I've
sometimes found those songs
in very obscure newspaper
articles.
Saying the board of,
you know, Jewish people
in this town met,
and they had songs.
And this person sang this song.
Sometimes I'll actually find
a documented performance.
But for this music
I'm not sure I would.
>> I was thinking
more generally, not.
>> Randall Goldberg: Yeah.
>> Necessarily specifically.
But was there, you know, was
there two-way communication?
Was it mostly, you talked about
this network that existed.
And how much support they felt
from what was happening here.
>> Randall Goldberg: Oh, the
community back in Russia.
>> Yes, yes.
>> Randall Goldberg:
That's a good question.
I know a lot of money
was raised.
And there was a lot of money
and there was a lot of all kinds
of benefits being done.
There was a lot of activity
in Washington about it.
They really wanted
the U.S. government,
people really wanted the U.S.
government to get involved.
I'm not sure what happened
in those communities though.
I can't think of anything.
You know, mostly what I read
in my research was all
these writers visiting there
and then writing about it.
For example, that Irish
author I mentioned.
There's some famous
Jewish poets who went there
and wrote these other poems.
Ones called I think
"Streets of Blood."
That all Israelis now,
I believe, know very,
am I getting the
name of it right?
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah, but what's?
>> Bialik poem.
>> Randall Goldberg:
Yeah, the Bialik poem.
>> His response.
>> Randall Goldberg: Right.
He went there.
>> [inaudible] a year after.
The city of.
>> Randall Goldberg:
"The City of Blood."
[ Inaudible Comment ]
Yeah, "City of Blood."
Right. And so some in of
these works of [inaudible].
I know that I've gotten
away from your question.
But, yeah, I'm not sure
about what the people
in the community knew.
I know they knew funding
was coming in and,
you know, aid and help.
But a lot of them were just
mostly probably trying to get
out of there and get to America.
1903 they could still immigrate.
>> Great. Well, thanks so much.
We really appreciate it.
>> Randall Goldberg:
Well, thanks a lot.
Thanks for having me.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.